vanessa paradis et johnny depp ch et un
couple parfait c'est le bonheur absolu
donc on va faire une interview je fous
la merde
j'ai toujours amoureuse de johnny depp
n'est toujours pas mariés donc
vous serez pas qu'il est un peu moins
bon sur man
city font
suite à une vilaine verrues plantaires
c'est un dommage d'être tout le temps
séparés dans sérieux justement n'est pas
tout le temps c'est vrai
il néglige pas là non non c'est caen qui
vous ai dit je t'aime pour la dernière
fois
vous avez cadeau qui vous a fait c'est
quoi une valise
non je sais pas si j'ai des belles roses
pour la fête des morts il vachement
attentionné c'est génial
quand ils offrent des fleurs il dit pas
sa secrétaire de le faire c'est lui qui
va vraiment les achetés au magasin
il n'oublie jamais votre anniversaire
je vis de votre en compte non plus non
mais celle-ci l'internet pour savoir
s'il est parfait moi je vous le confirme
tout de suite et il est parfait
vous engueuler parfois quand même
peuvent bien sûr qu'il est parfait il
oublie de relever la cuvette des
toilettes
non jamais non c'est un mec formidable
non ça se voit c'est quoi qui vous
énerve le plus chez lui
qu'on le fasse pas nous il a des défauts
mais j'aime ses défauts et voulait mais
il est pardonné il laisse traîner ses
chaussettes
bah ouais mais j'aimerais pas qui
arrange tout c'est un vrai bond énorme
effet chez c à vous est folle de lui on
va dire il a un petit peu un tempérament
de feu ouais et qui sait pas toujours
très facile mais moi ça me plaît
c'est cuit à l'eau
vincent rottiers
ça dure c'est laurent bâti tué sur paris
là il peut passer oui bonjour vincent 20
tonnes qui on est à l'antenne tu es sur
paris
est ce que tu peux passer s'il te plaît
à la plaine saint denis
c'est vanessa nadine ans et vanessa
paradis qui a parlé de toi la dictée
était formidable et je te la passe ton
chemin de toi le cul on t'attend
moi aussi je t'embrasse
je te passe vanessa à l'eau
non mais si toi
non mais
c'est mais ouais mais je n'y suis pour
rien j'ai juste voulu dire des jeux
suivants
non plus
à venir mais non ils veulent que tu n'en
vient pas du fait de son
état
[Applaudissements]
mon âge
wen mais il ya plein mon nom mais il a
mieux à faire il à la fête de la musique
c'est ça c'est bien cette semaine tandis
que la faille à la tête du top amoureuse
de lui mais j'ai beaucoup de tendresse
pour lui je l'adoré mais c'est bien et
c'est ainsi pas sonné samedi a pu la
fête de la musique c'est monaco qui
vient
à l'est
vanessa je t'adore
ça jusqu'à johnny depp jeu serait jaloux
mois
elle tu adores
l habitat 18 balles étaient hyper mignon
à la d'immeubles il venait d'avoir 18
ans à la même chanté enfin il dit que
c'est une belle aventure avec toi mais
qui passe de minutes à nous raconter bon
tout à l'heure on t'attend
je crois qu'il va passer de mettre les
choses au point
bon
deux trois petites questions qui voilà
donc il est parfait c'est johnny depp
est évidemment il râle pas quand il faut
descendre la poubelle
non les râler
il a des manies qui vous énerve quand
même voilà
quand même bien mais quand même vous
l'avez déjà chopé encore regarder un
film porno non non
bon ben c'est sans espoir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux